قال مصدر ملاحي للجزيره ان عددا من
الناقلات والسفن التجاريه العابره من مضيق
باب المندب شرعت في اخفاء هويتها ووجهتها
عن طريق اغلاق نظام التعريف الالي خشيه
استهدافها من جماعه الحوثي وحسب المصدر
الملاحي فانه مع اغلاق السفن لنظام
التعريف الالي فانها تصبح غير قابله
للتتبع لكنها قد تثير الشكوك لدى جماعه
الحوثي وقد يرسلون زوارق للاقتراب من
السفينه بغيه التاكد من
هويتها معنا من جيبوتي مراسل الجزيره حسن
رزاق حسن مع هذه الاجراءات الجديده وال
الاليات ايضا ما الذي يرصد ويسجل من وتيره
لحركه هذه السفن ونطاق
ابحارها
بفعل مريم هنا في جبوتي المطله على ساحر
البحر الاحمر وايضا القريبه من مضيق باب
المندب الذي يعتبر احد اهم الممرات
المائيه في العالم لازال التوتر هو سيد
الموقف احدث الخطوات التي بدات تتخذها
السفن الاسرائيليه او المتوجهه لاسرائيل
هو اغلاق نظام التعريف الالي او ما يعرف
بت ترافيك سيستم حتى لا تعرف هويتها
ووجهتها وبالتالي خشيه استهدافها من جماعه
الحوث لكن اكدت المصادر ان هذا الاخفاء
يثير الشكوك لدى جماعه الحوث التي بدات
ترسل زوارق للاقتراب من هذه السفينه وهو
ما يثير الشكوك ايضا هناك خيارات اخرى
لبعض السفن طبعا هذا الحصار المفروض على
السفن الاسرائيليه وال او المتج الاسرائيل
ليس حصارا على كافه الملاحه الدوليه هنا
لكن فقط ينحصر على هذه السفن الاسرائيل
ايضا بعد السفن بدات تقترب من الساحل
الافريقي او الضفه الغربيه لباب المندب
خشيه الابتعاد عن الساحل الاس او الساحل
اليمني حتى لا يتم استهدافها لكن المياه
السطحيه هنا ليست عميقه وبالتالي الشاحنات
ا او الناقلات او السفن التي يزداد حمولته
عن 100000 طن لا تستطيع ان تتحرك بسهوله
فهي رحله محفوفه بالمخاطر الخيار الاخير
حتى هذه اللحظه التي بدات تسلكه كافه
السفن المتوجهه لاسرائيل تخشى هو الذهاب
من راس الرجاء الصالح وهو ما يزيد الكلفه
في المسافه وايضا في التامين عليها على اي
حال لازالت التوترات هنا مستمره ايضا بحسب
ما اشارت لنا المصادر ان المواجهات
المستمره بين
بعض المق نعم اشكرك حسن رزاق من
جيبوتي